je sens inverse lento ils peuvent
conférer travaux sur samba verlaine à
cause de la barbe des voitures sont
maraboutés ravi est il vrai que tu as
commencé à boire quand et épreuve pour
ne pas payer et c'est la vérité car je
bégayais abominablement tiens j'ai été
professeur de philosophie
j'ai eu 30 elle est il y en a 29 qui ont
été reçus après bourges et fait deux ans
en allemagne et en me disant la
philosophie c'est génial mais pourquoi
est-ce que 29 bat ont été reçus et ben
ils ont été reçus parce que sans
permanent c'est comme si il redoublait
car j'aurais été deux france que j'avais
alors oui par le bébé est mort
exactement il n'était plus beaux arts
florissants
c'est en voit ensemble on est sous tous
eu l'explication de télé bien on n'est
pas sous avec eux on échoue avec soi
même et bien moi je dissous quant à moi
je dirais
quand je vois qu'ils passaient l'enfance
que je voulais double yaya touré gaza à
se projette et si l'une langage bourse
de merci à yves à ce jour tué quatre
mecs comme moi dans une version je me
vois quatre et c'est pas fini
ce soir je serai 8
autre phrase de ce jeune homme fringant
je ne vous en veux pas car on trinque
pas avec une seringue aucune sur un nom
et avec une double sera dans un bon
petit verre ça va tout seul paris on
peut mettre aussi le buzz depuis
l'injection
oui scénario enfin si on peut pas faire
autrement s'il vous plaît pour nous deux
agréments d'axa est il vrai j'ai ouï
dire que quand tu écris tu arrêtes de
loueurs mais au wagon c'est la vérité
mais j'ai écrit de moins en moins ah oui
qatar doit de plus en difficile ça me
trompe moi un truc marrant tu as un
point encore interdit
on aime les filles et komisarek je suis
allée 33 ans au commissariat de police
donc 33 mètres avec les passes toujours
avec les pinces qu'il retirera pour que
je puisse me moucher vous faire autre
chose exactement couler un bon soi même
et se faire couler par quelqu'un d'autre
c'est tout rose ont changé de lieu
on n'a pas convaincu et de deux
deux pour être exact la valeur dans
l'alcool et bien une chose que je ne
ferai jamais décrire aspects de la
france et rival je les fais j'ai écrit
dans l'humanité ofi house éclectisme
allons la gauche me croit droite la
droite on croit de gauche entre les deux
mois je porte à gauche mais plus bas
canon
un ricanement à ta santé
je rentre ce soir
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu